Hi, I flew in from Australia the day before
yesterday.
I'm not saying that I'm the most jet lagged
person here, but I would appreciate it if
you could all just put in a little bit of
effort to laugh at my jokes.
That would really make things easier for me!
So, the event loop.
A couple of years back, here at this very
conference, a guy by the name of Phil Roberts
did a talk called "What the heck is the event
loop anyway?"
If you haven't seen it, I highly recommend
you check it out.
It is on the JSConf YouTube chapel.
It is pretty fucking exciting because it catches
on fire!
In case you haven't seen it, though.
It is an overview of the event loop, the different
components, and how they work together.
If you haven't seen it, we will do a quick
overview of the things that are relevant for
today, and then we are going to do a deep
dive into specific parts of the event loop.
So, you can think of the event loop as, like,
the main function of the browser.
It's just an infinite loop.
It's going to grab a task off the task queue,
and it's going to run that task.
Which is great, but what is a task?
So a task is how JavaScript gets run.
If we have a bit of a script like this, we
can see JavaScript in there.
The browser will parse this script tag and
create the task.
So the code with the dark background is going
to be a task.
When it gets run, it's going to create a variable,
it's going to do something, and it's going
to register this event listener, and, then,
whenever the browser gets a keydown event,
the bit of blue is going to run as a task.
Every bit of JavaScript that runs as a task
could be a script or could be a callback.
What does execute task do?
It runs the code.
What about the taskQueue.
That's what we are going to look at today.
We are going to look at taskQueues in the
context of browsers, and look at Node, and
we are going to have a real quick look at
web workers.
Constitutional.
So what is a taskQueue and what is it for?
It's where your code goes, where your JavaScript
goes while it's waiting to execute.
So, like before, we could parse a script tag,
we could have callback on a click event, we
could have a callback on a set time out.
They're going to go into our queue there,
and they're going to get executed.
The important thing is that it is a queue,
so things are going to get executed in the
order that they arrive - first in, first out
- and the other important thing is that a
task is going to run from start to finish.
There is no interrupted JavaScript.
You don't have to worry about concurrency,
locking, or any of that rubbish.
It is super easy.
Cool.
That's our event loop.
It turns out, though, it's a little bit more
complicated than that.
You see, the taskQueue works in conjunction
with the rendering pipeline.
The rendering pipeline is what it responsible
for painting things in the browser window,
so you make changes to the DOM, you update
your style, and then the rendering pipeline
runs and shows it on the screen.
So, the webbed pipeline can run after a task
finishes.
The task finishes, the rendering pipeline
can run, but browsers are pretty clever, right?
They don't like to do work that they don't
have to do, and there is really no point running
the rendering pipeline unless the screen's
about to refresh, so your average screen refresh
s 60 times a second, once every 16 milliseconds,
so, if we run a task, the rendering pipeline
is going to wait that 16 milliseconds before
it runs.
If it is not obvious, this is the slowed down
version.
It is turns out it is hard to see, at 60 frames
a second.
Sitting around doing nothing all that time
is a bit of a waste, so, in reality, the browser's
going to run a where did you go of tasks,
and then run the rendering pipeline.
The important thing is that the rendering
pipeline can't run until the task finishes.
If you've got a task that takes a really long
time, the rendering pipeline has to wait.
A couple of milliseconds here and there isn't
going to matter.
If you take tasks that take a lot more than
16 milliseconds, your web page is going to
start dropping frames and start running like
this.
If you do have long-running tasks, you can
split them up, so you can create new tasks
using something like setTimeout.
You can use would be workers because that's
what they are for.
So now, an event loop looks a bit like this.
We're going to run an infinite loop, pick
a task off the task cube, and run that task,
and then, if we're ready to repaint, we will
repaint.
That's cool, right?
It turns out, it's more complicated than that,
if you have a look at the spec, which I'm
sure we do in our spare time, you will see
that an event loop it have one or more taskQueues.
At this point, what I will do is I will have
a look at an query ... . [Sound distorted].
So, instead, we are going to look at a theoretical
browser with multiple taskQueue s.
To be clear, this is the example that is give
in the spec of having multiple taskQueues,
so I didn't make it - somebody else made it
up.
This browser prioritises mouse-click event.
It has got two taskQueues there.
One where our mouse click is going to go and
another queue where everything else goes.
This is really simple, it's like the business
class line at the airport.
It's going to run all of the tasks in the
mouse-click queue, and then the tasks in the
other queue.
It doesn't affect the rendering pipeline which
will run after each task in it wants to.
Super simple.
It doesn't have to be like that, right?
The browsers can actually execute the queues
in any order they like, so we could have taken
two off the mouse click queue and three off
the other queue - whatever we like.
The queues can be executed in any order.
But, the queues still do have to be queues.
So the tasks have to be executed in the order
that they arrive.
First in, first out.
All of our mouse-click events have to go in
that queue.
Node uses a specific queue for timeout event,
so all of the timeout events have to go in
that queue.
So this is how our event loop looks now: we've
got an infinite loop, we are going to pick
a queue, grab a task, and then it's time to
repaint, and we will repaint.
This is still straightforward, right?
It turns out, it's a little bit more complicated
than that, though.
We also have microtasks.
What is a microtask?
For the purposes of this 20-minute talk, a
microtask is a promise.
There are other things that generate microtasks
but 99.9 per cent of things that you do it's
going to be promises.
So our microtask queue is in yellow there
next to the rendering pipeline, and we have
a bit of code, it's going to run.
We have a promise that resolves, it goes in
the microtask queue.
Now, the microtask queue has a couple of special
properties.
First of all, it runs after every task, so
you finish a task, then you run the microtask
queue.
Even if the rendering pipeline would like
it run, it has to wait until the microtask
queue finishes.
If we have multiple tasks in the microtask
queue, they're all going to run.
If we add more while we are running it, those
will have to be run too, so this has some
important implications for how things run.
Let's have a quick look at the difference
between how tasks run and how microtasks run.
So this bit of code generates tasks.
I click the button, it's going to principle
out the number of tasks that it has run, and
then it's going to generate another task,
which is going to print out the number of
tasks that is run so on, and so order infinitely.
We can see it running, counting tasks, everything
is great, I can select text, I can click stop.
I can't click start again, because I didn't
implement that.
But, if we look at the same thing with microtasks,
things are a bit different.
So, if I start, so this is the same code,
right?
It is a coding and microtask, which is going
to print out the number of microtasks that
have run, and then create another microtask,
and keep looping, the same as the set setTimeout
but with promises.
If I click start promising, we can see everything
has immediately gone to shit.
The button has clicked but it hasn't unclicked,
right?
The cursor, which you can't see there, it's
still the little hand.
I can't select text.
I definitely can't click stop, which wouldn't
have helped because I didn't implement it
anyway, it's like I knew what was going to
happen.
This page is kaput.
If we wait a little bit longer, Chrome will
realise and tell us tell us but I don't have
that kind of time.
What happened there?
Exactly like we saw in the example, we are
stuck, just dealing with the microtask queue.
So the rest of the event loop is blocked,
we can't re-render the page, we can't do anything
else, we are stuck in the event loop - stuck
in the microtask queue.
So, yes.
Cool.
This is how our event loop looks now.
It's an infinite loop.
We are going to pick a queue, a task off that
queue, and run it.
As long as there are microtasks to round,
we're going to do microtasks, and, then.
Would it be fair to say that is done, if it
is time to repaint, we will repaint.
Cool, so this is starting to look a little
bit complicated but it turns out it's just
a little bit more complicated than this.
We also have the animation frame callback
queue which I'm going to call the animation
queue, because, if I keep saying animation
frame callback queue, this talk won't get
finished in time for lunch!
So you can add things to the animation queue
by calling request animation frame and passing
a callback.
Why would one do such a thing?
I'm using it here to run the animation of
the browser running into the browser right-hand
window into the pipeline.
I have my browser window and pipeline, and
I remove a class which resets the frame, and
then I add the slide class to the window which
gives it a -
which makes is slide down, through the magic
of transitions.
If I did it like this, as I said before, browsers
are clever, and they like to be helpful.
If I wrote this code, the browser would look
at it and say you've removed the class, and
then you've added the same class back again.
That's the same as doing nothing.
So, let's just do nothing.
Instead where I have to make sure that things
occur after - so to do one, I need the browser,
the window to refresh, and then I need to
do the next thing.
We have a look at how that works.
We've got our animation queue there in green
beside the rendering pipeline.
I've got my scripts running, and I call request
animation frame which adds something to the
animation queue.
You can see it's going to sit there, and nothing's
going to happen until we're ready to repaint,
and then we will run the animation queue,
and then we will repaint the browser.
Like the microtask queue, the animation queue
has a couple of special properties.
If I have multiple things in the animation
queue when it is ready to run, I'm going to
run all those things.
But, if I add more things to the animation
queue while it's running, I'm not going to
run those guys.
The reason for that is that, if you're creating
animations, you want to say this is what I
want to do in this frame, and then you're
going to set up what is going to happen in
the next frame but you don't want run it,
right?
You want to wait until the window has refreshed.
Cool.
So, this is what our event loop looks like
now.
It's an infinite loop.
We're going to pick a queue.
We're going to grab the first task off that
queue, and we're going to run the task.
Then, as long as there are microtasks, we're
going to run all those.
Then, if we're ready to repaint, we're going
to grab the animation tasks that are currently
in the queue, and we're going to run all of
those, and then we're going to repaint.
And that is as complicated as it gets.
But, what about node?
First of all, good news.
Node is a lot simpler than a browser.
It has no script-parsing events.
You're not picking JavaScript out of HTML
all over the place, you just give it a JavaScript
file and it runs it.
There is no users clicking on shit all over
the place.
You don't have to worry about animation framework
callbacks because there's no rendering pipeline.
There is also another — important difference
with Node: the browser event loop is like
a merry-go-round.
It just keeps going round and round and round.
The Node event loop, it's more like a roller
coaster.
It is going to run through one loop, and there's
more stuff to do, it will run through another
loop.
Once it's done, that's it.
It's done.
So, the Node event loop: Node has three queues
that are interesting enough to talk about
today.
It's got one queue for all of your event callbacks,
so your XHR requests, your disk reads and
writes and that stuff will go in the first
queue.
They're called phases in nodes.
The second phase is the check phase.
And the third phase is your timers this that's
all of your timers for callback and set interval
will go into that third queue.
Node is going to run everything in the event
callback queue; it's going to run then everything
in the check queue.
Once that is done, it's going to run everything
in the timer queue.
Then, if there is more stuff, it will loop
back around and run through the queues again.
As soon as there is no task in any queues,
and there are no event waiting anywhere, it
will finish.
It will end.
So, how do you add stuff to the check phase?
You can add things to the check phase queue
by calling setImmediate and parsing a callback.
setImmediate is the same as setTimeout with
a time of zero, but because of the way the
queues work, if you call setTimeout with a
time of zero, and setImmediate, your setImmediate
is going to run first.
Node also has promises.
Just like the browser, and Node promises work
just the same as browser promises — after
each task finishes, we will run the promise
microtask queue.
Node also has another micro task queue which
is the nextTick queue.
You can parse a callback.
It works just the same.
There's nothing really interesting there.
The major difference is, if you have both
promises and nextTick callbacks becomes all
your nextTick callbacks will run before your
promises, but that's pretty much it.
The only new things, different things in Node
are setImmediate and process.next tick.
Pro why are they named like that?
It turns out naming things are hard.
You guys all know the two hard problems in
computer signs, right?
Validation, and naming things, and off by
one errors.
So this is our Node event loop.
It's only going to run while there are still
task.
It's going to pick a queue, and then, while
that queue has more tasks, it's going to grab
the next task in that queue, it's going to
run that task, and then while the next tick
queue has more tasks, it's going to run all
the next tick queue tasks, and then, while
the promise queue has more tasks, it's going
to do the promises.
So that just leaves web workers.
Anyone who is not familiar with Australian
wildlife, this is a redback spider.
Unlike most Australian wildlife, they're not
that dangerous.
Nobody has died from a redback spider bite
since the 1950s.
Probably don't get bitten by one, though.
So web workers: web workers turn out to be
dead simple.
Each web worker run in its own thread.
It has got its own event loan, got its own
stack, task queue — everything just runs
on its own.
It's even easier than Node.
So there are no script tags.
Again, you parse in a JavaScript file.
There are no user interactions.
Web workers aren't allowed to manipulate the
DOM so you don't have to worry about any animation
frames or anything like that.
If we look at a demo, we can generate a task,
call a setTimeout, make HSR requests, we can
send and receive post-message events, so,
post-message is how your web worker communicates
with the browser window.
And we can make promises.
It's — that's it.
It's just really easy.
Yes.
So, that's a event — that's the event loop.
Things to remember: long-running tasks will
make your page run like a wonky cat.
Promises and nextTick tasks can make it run
like a dead cat.
Make sure you break your tasks up into small
pieces and don't have infinitely recursive
promises and nextTick tasks.
Node is a bit different to the browser.
It's going to run through the event loop only
as long as there are things to do.
It has got those three specific tasks, and
it's got setImmediate and process.nextTick.
Web workers do their own thing, in their own
event loop, and completely separate from anything
else that is going on.
Remember, the event loop is more exciting
than you can possibly have imagined!
Thank you.
[Applause].